[Music]
people are still talking about it the
office they would love for you to come
back into a reboot would you be down for
something like that I don't know what
form it would take or anything I'm sort
of agnostic I love whatever has anything
to do with that show but it's all very
hypothetical right now I've talked to
Steve about a year ago he said he would
not want to do it I think people would
be disappointed I really do
there's kind of you can't you can't go
home again that way I think I want a
reunion with just the cast would you be
down to party with Steve at his house
for our office reunion oh yeah
I'll bring the nachos funny man Edie
Helms keeping hope alive for an office
revival at the premiere for his new
movie Chappaquiddick what the hell
happened Teddy the film centers around
the fatal 1969 car accident involving
Senator Ted Kennedy and the death of
young campaign strategist Mary Jo
Kopechne II there's not a lot of
senators that are charged with
manslaughter that go on to become
president it's just always important to
put a spotlight on abuse of power and
and any kind of corruption and and to
question our heroes sometimes
[Music]
[Applause]
you